laughs
Sister Wives star Robin Brown breaks
down in Mary's arms following a family
fight with Christine she's treated you
like dirt from the very beginning that's
the relationship you have with her
and that's the reason I'm angry I think
this is one of the saddest conversations
I've ever been in
I don't regret leaving at all though
right now I'm requiring a bit of a
distance to be honest with you I feel
like I'm just starting to get to know me
I really like me and I want to keep it
that way and that distance is exactly
what triggered the emotional moment
Christine breaks the news she's moving
to Utah following her split from Cody
and she tells them she wants some
distance from everyone but Janelle
do see us getting together for family
reunions and I do see us having fun
together and is that the extent of what
you want
just a family reunion for now yeah I
think Janelle and I are super close but
I'm not that close with
the rest of you and for right now
I kind of need it that way
it's kind of that last little bit of
Hope
sort of dying
I'm super close with Chanel I don't know
if you can be Sister Wives you know if
you're not really but I just consider
tell my sister if she just always will
be and so we vacation together and we've
hung out together so we're fine together
as for Mary she's not surprised by
Christine's wishes she doesn't want to
work on anything and I have seen
her non-acceptance of Robin and I have
seen her disdain for me through the
years so
as much as it hurts me
um I'm I'm glad to know where she
actually sounds I won't be close with
Mary anymore not really we're just a
very different and so we we won't I
won't really be having that much to do
with Mary so much you know I wish her
the best I wish her all the happiness in
the world of course and whatever she
needs I hope she gets that I just don't
see that there's a friendship for us but
when Robin starts to get emotional Cody
gets angry and explodes on Christine you
never tried to have really good
relationship with these other people
and that's the reason I'm pissed off
that's not true it's just I did vomiting
out of me because I've sat here with it
just like Christine try and do this you
wanted to renegotiate a relationship
with me but you wouldn't even have a
decent one with them it's easy to start
pointing the other ugly finger of blame
and so no I don't just blame myself
but I do believe that as we go through
struggles there's always plenty of blame
to spread around but even after all the
yelling it's still hard for Robin to
accept what Christine wants it sounds
like you'll continue to have the
relationships with the people you're
close with and
um those that you aren't close with then
they'll just you just wanted to stay
distant
all right for right now
sorry to see you go
as for Christine she divulges why she
wants her space from her two former
Sister Wives I feel like there's been
some things set against me behind my
back
so do I want to be friends with someone
who complains about me behind my back
well not right now and I think that
everybody's still it's hard when you
live it and then when you get to see it
and relive it again it's very difficult
emotionally so right now while the
episodes are airing it's all very raw
again
so right now it's a little more
difficult because we're seeing the
episodes too
[Music]
thank you